hey guys check out that sweet mountain
over there whoa are we not in Los
Angeles anymore
psyche it's visual effects one of those
useful tools that you can have in your
filmmaking repertoire is the ability to
do matte paintings I met ping lets you
create a world or illustrate a scene
that otherwise would be impossible
because it's not actually there and
matte paintings are actually relatively
easy to do and they're very effective at
making people think that they're in some
magical land or some foreign country or
any other area that's actually quite
hard to get to or create so the trick
with the matte painting is you want to
think about what this world is that
you're creating and where the elements
are going to be ideally if you're going
into like a dialogue scene you don't
place a matte painting element right
behind an actor because that means in
every single shot in the dialogue scene
you need to show that element which
that's a lot of work so generally
speaking a matte painting is used as a
very wide shot before you get into the
scene it sets the stage describes the
environment and then you move in for
close-ups and medium shots with your
actors and you forget about what the
horizon looks like so matte paintings
tend to only really be used once or
twice in the scene which makes them also
great for being a quick and easy effect
while being very effective things to
think about when you're doing a matte
painting is camera motion how much
motion blur you have and whether or not
things are out of focus when you're
shooting a shot for matte painting you
want to try to avoid having translating
camera movement you don't want your
camera moving actually moving around to
space what you really want to do is have
the camera in one spot doing a look
around we like to call this a nodal pan
that's what it's called
buzu but I know After Effects refers to
it as like a tripod pan I really can
just think of it as the camera being in
one spot and just rotating around kind
of like your eyeballs in your head or
your head like this without walking
around because the reason for shooting a
nodal pan is because there's no parallax
what is parallax well let me demonstrate
here's my hand in the foreground here's
my hand the background whoa my hands are
moving against each other because of the
parallax that makes things really hard
to composite it makes things really hard
to track especially when you're trying
to put mountains a hundred miles in the
distance with clouds it's a lot easier
to have a nodal pan because wherever you
put the object is
to be locked out from the scene so now
we have our footage in the computer
we're going to take it into After
Effects and show you how to do some
matte painting let's take a look so the
very first thing you can do with your
footage is drag it down to the create
new composition button went and set in
and out points on the area where we want
to do the matte painting and we are
running after effects camera solver now
as you can see you have a couple
different options for the type of camera
solve in this case we're going to pick a
tripod pan because it's accurate the
camera motion we're not on a tripod its
handheld the same idea of the camera
rotating around one central mode anyways
now we can take a look at our track
points see if it's solid and if they are
create a camera out of it another thing
you can do is select the points and
create a solid or null in that area and
see if it sticks to the background it
looks like it's sticking to the
background you have a successful track
sweet so now the next step is to save a
frame so here I go to save frame as file
I can save a Photoshop frame now the
reason I like to save a frame this matte
painting is because rather than setting
everything up in After Effects and
having to work with all the elements in
After Effects the matte painting I
actually like to do that in Photoshop I
kind of rough in my positions of the
objects I can deal with any tweaks the
elements I'm going to have such as
removing backgrounds dealing with you
know masks and feathering color
adjustments all that kind of stuff makes
a little bit easier so anyways I drop
the frame into Photoshop we're going to
add the matte painting so I'm gonna take
this classy mountain image here got
enough the internet and we're going to
use the quick selection tool to remove
the background so this is a perfect
example of why I like using Photoshop to
work with the elements because this is
way faster in Photoshop as opposed to
After Effects
so anyways go through take my sweet
mountain paste it in here and now I can
kind of position it and see where I want
it see if the size is going to work
see if I maybe need a different mountain
do some transformations here up I see
that this spot on the right is actually
kind of poking out weirdly on the edge
of the photo so I can manipulate that
here so once again you can you know you
can paint the light onto your objects
can deal with changing the shadows just
generally speaking Photoshop is better
for actually building the elements and
then we're all done we'll save the PSD
file so we can bring it back into After
Effects and actually position those
elements into the final shot always
maximize the compatibility anyways we're
going to take the Photoshop file and
bring it back into After Effects
now when you import it by default it's
going to import as a composition which
is perfect so you can work with the
layers separately if you need to anyways
we're going to take the PSD file and
just drop it right into the timeline
kind of line it up here now this is a 2d
file we're just we use this for
reference here we're going to duplicate
it and create a 3d version of the
mountain which is way off in space
because it's Flint we're using a 3d
camera here we're actually going to
bring it back in and align it with the
two-dimensional version of the layer
that's already lined up kind of make
sure it's all fitting make sure it's all
working we're using the 2d one as a
template or a realign the 3d one now the
thing you'll notice with matte paintings
and After Effects so you're working in
3d space so can be kind of a pain to
realign everything and put it all back
into place but that's or something
you're gonna have to deal with anyways
once it's lined up here we can check
make sure it's sticking looks pretty
sweet looks like there's a mountain kind
of in front of all these buildings but
somehow still there so the next step
here is masking since you have a motion
track scene it'll actually be pretty
easy in this case I'm going to create a
solid same resolution as the comp and
I'm going to make the solid a 3d solid
so it's in 3d space now here's a cool
trick if you hold shift while parenting
one object to another the object will
inherit all the position and rotation
properties of the object that you just
parented it to in this case the solid is
right where the mountain is so scale it
up a little bit so it covers the scene
and now we're ready to do some masking
to get those buildings to be in front of
the mountain so anyways I've hidden the
solid layer by still haven't selected
going to my pen tool I'm going to start
drawing a mask on all these buildings
here as you can see I'm going super fast
anyways here we go mask is in place on
the solid there you can see it and
there's the mountain behind the solid
and now in this case we use a track mat
since it's all white I'm going to use a
luma matte but you can also use an alpha
matte for a solid now the track matte
causes the mountain to be behind the
area where the matte is basically hiding
the bottom half and because the white
solid is a 3d solid in the track space
the masa we've drawn is all tracked
correctly to the buildings so we don't
have to do any math keyframes or
anything it's all perfectly locked off
good to go
so the next step here if you want to
preserve those power lines those are way
too thin to be masked out we got a handy
trick here so I'm gonna duplicate the
footage layer and now I can use color
keying or luma keying to bring in any
fine details in this case I'm use a
color difference key
key out the blue of the sky and keep the
powerlines in some of the clouds in
front of the mountain so this case I
picked use the eyedropper and some of
the sliders to control all the different
values and you'll have to mess around
with the different settings for you know
whatever your shot happens to be in this
case I can key up the blue I can keep
the power lines and I can keep the
clouds and really make it look like that
mountain is actually there in the sky
behind some that atmosphere looks really
nice and really convincing it's a great
way to preserve some of this detail that
otherwise would require a ton of really
nitpicky masking to fix so here we have
it looks pretty good really looks like
it's there and it tracks really solidly
and it's really a really fast effect to
do you can see how he did it in just a
couple minutes and it's super convincing
so I think you guys don't really like
this effect it really empowers you as a
filmmaker and opens up a lot of create
creative ways for you to bring a world
to life so have fun motion tracking that
footage
you